hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others
and I see all sorts of questions stored
up here
uh one from Aaron if human reaction
speed was faster would that be helpful
how much faster could it be is the
limiting factor the nerve signal relays
or brain processing time okay
interesting question so first of all
what is human reaction time it's like
you see a light flash you press a button
takes about 0.3 seconds give or take
um and 300 milliseconds 300 000 of a
second
um
I think it varies a bit with uh you know
uh
it it it probably varies a bit with sort
of Age and alertness and all that kind
of thing and people who play video games
all the time maybe it's faster I'm not
sure I'm not sure how trainable it is
um I do know that for example if you're
tapping your finger that's one of those
things where you know the speed of
tapping your finger people typically are
their fastest at the age 20 or something
they're not at their fastest at age five
and that sort of steadily declines from
that so I'm told
um the uh
I think the question of what's taking
that point three seconds
it's not the nerve impulse time that is
oh let's see we can probably work it out
but it's a small fraction of that time I
believe I remember working this out at
one point that if you just look at nerve
conduction speeds so you know in order
to essentially what has to happen is you
see light flash things have got to
happen in your brain then your brain has
got to generate an electrical signal
that goes down nerves that come from
your brain to your spinal cord out from
your spinal cord into the nerves in your
arm and eventually to the nerves that
actuate the muscles in your finger and
then there has to be an electrical
signal that causes the fibers in your
muscle to contract and then you move
your finger
um and uh I think that the um
um
um the kind of uh uh the effective
distance that one goes is around 100
meters that is that it's like it's as if
if if we were
if we were a huge animal you know the
Brontosaurus or something maybe
brontosaurus says quotes don't exist
anymore in addition to having gone
extinct as dinosaurs I think the naming
of dinosaurs got changed as a result of
uh discovering that museum specimens
weren't assembled the way they were
supposed to be assembled and so on so
the Brontosaurus may be doubly extinct
but anyway it was a very long animal
that had you know a very big distance
from the brain and its head to the tip
of its tail and you could imagine that
the reaction time for flipping its tail
would be determined by the time uh for
the signal to go from the eye of the
Brontosaurus in its head down to the the
tip of the tail so to speak
um and you know that could be a long
distance it won't be 100 meters there's
no creature that big I think
um
no even whales are not that big the um
uh
but um uh maybe I should use the example
of a whale as something which has a sort
of Fairly long distance
um the uh uh to get from its from its
brain to its tail so to speak in any
case so part of the time is spent in
nerve conduction from the brain to the
finger but that's a small fraction of
the time at least for us humans and most
of the time is in effect signals
bouncing around inside our brains and
what tends to happen is that you have to
kind of form the thought that you're
going to move your finger
and you can actually measure if you look
at electrical signals in the brain there
is a motor strip I think it's at the top
one's head around here that is the part
that is sort of actually in a sense
connected to the nerves that go to
fingers and so on and there's a
pre-motor strip which starts showing
electrical activity sooner than the
motor strip I think it happens at like
0.1 seconds or something whereas it
takes uh it takes you know 0.25 seconds
or more to get props that are proper
activity ready to actually drive your
finger so to speak and back in the day
people were thinking about you know
having uh things that would pick up
electrical signals from the brain as a
way to control military planes faster
than they could otherwise be controlled
things like that it's in the category it
might not be a good idea because it
might be the case that you know you're
starting to form the thought I should
press the trigger so to speak but then
some other signals inside your brain
maybe from your frontal lobes or some
such other thing come in and say no no
that's a really bad idea don't do it and
that all happens in the full 0.3 seconds
but in 0.1 seconds if you were to pick
up kind of the first Beginnings the
formation of that thought to press the
button or something then you would end
up concluding you should press the
button a lot of times when actually it
was a really bad idea to do that but any
case so I think that the um uh the vast
majority of the time of reaction time is
spent sort of bouncing around inside
your brain uh kind of trying to form the
thought decide what to do set things up
so that you're going to send that signal
to the to the nerves that go to the
fingers so to speak
um now one can think about as one
understands more about how neural Nets
are put together and so on the brain
every neuron kind of it's like a relay
there's one neuron fires but it's an
electrical signal it affects another
neuron another neuron another neuron
there's this whole sort of train of
neurons and the brain is probably
arranged in sort of layers of neurons a
little bit like the neural Nets that
exist in the chat gpts of this world and
so on and you can ask questions like how
many layers of neurons are going through
what's the delay
going from one neuron to another neuron
through the synapse where there's a
connection where one neuron has a sort
of a piece an axon that sticks out from
the neuron that then has uh has an
actual it has actual uh ions that go
from from one
um uh from one sort of transmit the
electricity from one nerve cell to the
next and uh that happens I think more
slowly than sort of the than the sort of
conduction down the wire that has one
piece of the neuron and typically
neurons if you if you look at neurons in
the brain for example they are they have
sort of a central body and they have
lots and lots of kind of very long
tentacles maybe 10 000 long long kind of
tentacle pieces sometimes they just go
straight from the body sometimes they
branch and so on and uh it um
those are the things down which
electrical signals are transmitted to
reach other neurons and the fact that
there's sort of so many connections from
each neuron is kind of one of the one of
the big things about brains is that the
neurons are connected to many other
neurons and there's a very complicated
network of connections that's what we
see in the Chachi BTS of this world
where there might be an attract GPT
there might be a few million neurons
but a hundred billion connections so
every individual neuron has a very large
number of Connections in the Chachi BT
artificial neural net as well as in
things like brains
so I think
in uh uh the another question you might
ask is when you look at human reaction
times
how much variation is there I mean if
you're doing the pressure finger press
your finger press your finger seeing the
light so to speak
um and you do that many times how much
what is what is the kind of curve of you
know do you ever hit it in 0.1 seconds
or is it always 0.28 0.31 you know this
kind of thing I saw those curves
actually fairly recently they they they
um they kind of come up fairly steeply
and then they have a pretty long tail so
it isn't a distribution where it's sort
of a oh there's an average kind of
reaction time and it's a kind of
bell-shaped curve a gaussian curve for
example around that average reaction
time it's a um it's a it's a thing I'm
not quite sure what the distribution is
but it's a distribution that is uh sort
of uh lopsided it um the the chance that
you have a very very short reaction time
is lower than the chance that you have
and an unexpectedly long reaction time
actually it's sort of interesting
because
and you can kind of ask the question
is it almost as if there's sort of a a
an artificial temperature to the brain
where because there's there's curves
that describe for example the the speeds
of molecules in a gas things like this
um and the the distribution of sort of
reaction times looks rather like that
curve the Maxwell distribution I I don't
know whether that's totally coincidental
or not I'm kind of suspecting it might
be rather coincidental
but now the question is well what if our
nerve transmission speeds were higher
well so in the case of of actual nerves
the myelin sheath around the nerve is
important to having fast transmission
speeds and so in diseases like multiple
sclerosis that destroy that myelin
sheath one of the problems is that that
transmission process does not work as
well I think it's more leaky but I think
it's also I I think it's also slower but
it's certainly more more leaky and and
so I think that's an important
um uh you know you you can imagine how
do you get how would you get faster
transmission of nerve impulses down a uh
a nerve now I I think that um the squid
has this giant axon very big piece of a
nerve cell and I think the one of the
things that a squid is really good at is
uh you know you poke one end of the
squid and the other end of the squid
responds so like like you know you poke
one end of the squid and the squid will
split out a bunch of ink or something
like this and I think one of the things
that is true about the giant axon of the
squid a much much thicker bigger
transmission line than we humans have
very convenient for people who do
experiments or nerve cells because they
can use the the the axon of the squid
um it's much easier to stick an
electrode into that than it isn't a
little tiny nerve cells that exist in
things like you know humans and mammals
and mice and whatever else
um and I think that one of the things
that's that's true about the squid uh
transaxon setup is that it has faster
transmission of double impulses
um I have to say I'm not completely
immediately sure let's see can I work
out why that is
um not immediately
and it may not be obvious why why it
works that way but so one could imagine
a situation where you have sort of
bigger thicker nerves that transmit data
more quickly in US humans
I think
to
uh
to imagine you know could you speed up
the brain could you make it so that the
nerve signals get transmitted more
quickly you know when you put
various kinds of chemicals drugs and so
on into the brain uh they definitely
don't tend to have that effect because
they affect the transmission of nerve
signals from one nerve cell to another
they affect kind of the environment of
the nerve cells and they can do things
like oh for example alcohol effects uh
transmission from one nerve cell to
another and I think makes that
transmission less uh less effective than
it would usually be but I don't think
anybody knows oh you you take this
chemical you put in your brain and
suddenly all the um the Transmissions
were more important actually actually no
that's not right there there are things
that enhance the transmission from one
nerve cell to another and that's not a
good thing actually because that that
means it's kind of like well you can
have more thoughts but uh having more
thoughts will tend to be more confusing
rather than uh you know I think a key
thing in the way that we think is we
tend to think in this kind of linear
chain of experience and if you start
saying well it's just you know have more
thoughts happening then the thing tends
to get sort of more confused and it's
less coherent kind of process of
thinking
but I suppose the question might be if
you uh so I don't think sort of it
increasing the rate of transmission from
one nerve cell to another is probably
something that in normal circumstances
is a very good thing to do increasing
the speed of transmission along a nerve
fiber I'm not sure how you would do that
other than by having a different nerve
nerve fiber
um or nerve uh
um
different collection of nerves
um I do Wonder a little bit for the very
big animals how the transmission of
things down these nerve fibers works now
by the way it's worth remembering that
squids in the deep ocean can get very
very big squids have this feature it's
kind of convenient if you're a conically
shaped animal that um you can just keep
growing it doesn't uh you know there's
your shape is a kind of a similar shape
it just keeps growing growing and
growing growing growing getting thicker
and thicker
um kind of like a a tree can potentially
keep growing with its trunk up and up
um it doesn't uh it um but so squids can
get pretty big
um now you know it's always said that
you know lots of dinosaurs for example
were sort of said to have multiple
brains that was a very common kind of uh
claim at least when I was a kid
and like the stegosaurus uh you know
it's got a little tiny brain in its head
and you can see it's a tiny brain
because its skull doesn't have much room
to have a bigger brain and then the
question is well how did it how did it
wag its tail uh I have to say a
Stegosaurus has this big kind of uh
assembly of spikes at the end of its
tail so wagging might not be quite the
thing for the stegosaurus the happy
stegosaurus might not be a a tail wagger
I'm not sure but in any case the um
uh the thing that was often claimed is
that it sort of had a secondary mini
brain in at the back that would sort of
help deal with things happening at the
back of the stegosaurus somewhat
independent of what's happening in the
in the main brain so to speak now the
fact is that all animals
um the the walking motion for example is
partly controlled by ganglia clumps of
nerves in the spinal cord and uh that
means you know one one some aspect of
the way one walks sort of isn't directly
controlled by the brain it's something
where your brain is just saying okay go
ahead and walk
and the the actual motion is being
orchestrated by some sort of lower level
uh set of things in the spinal cord and
presumably that's kind of the sense in
which the stegosaurus had a secondary
brain it wasn't that it could have a
discussion you know okay head what do
you think tail what do you think and it
could have sort of a back and forth I
don't think that was what was happening
just like I don't think we get to have a
um a back and forth with the ganglier
and our spinal cord and in fact uh our
impression of the world that sort of our
impression of Consciousness is there's
only one place where things are
happening so to speak I mean we would we
don't have an internal sense of where
that place is but the impression from
sort of the science side of it is it's
all happening in the brain it's not like
oh you know I'm trying to solve this
problem let me solve it in a ganglion in
my spinal cord I don't think so I don't
think that's how it works I think that
those ganglia are used merely for kind
of the once you've sort of decided what
you're going to do make it happen now
some of those things happen
independently of the brain like for
example the standard knee reflects where
you where you kind of uh hit right below
your kneecap and your leg your leg kind
of uh
uh pokes out
um that is a reflex that happens purely
in the spinal cord interesting question
is how much faster that happens than
something that has to knock around your
brain my assumption is it happens
significantly faster and in a sense
that's an example of well you don't
think about it and so it can sort of
just use the pure nerve cell Loop rather
than having to go through all of that
complicated stuff in the brain where you
say should I press the button or not
so anyway some some thoughts on um
uh
kind of
reaction times nerve cells nerve
transmissions stegosauruses and other
kinds of things
let's see
uh
Anon asks do I find it odd that on the
earth animals with bigger brains are
more intelligent but in technology
small smarter computer chips always seem
to be smaller I'm not sure that either
of those claims is quite right
um first point is
if
okay what what are our brains used for
part of it is controlling all of our
muscles you need a certain amount of
brain just to be able to control all the
muscles you have so if you're a whale
you need a big brain just because you're
going to have kind of the the base
connections the base neurons that are
going to deal with the muscles that are
in some piece of your tail separate from
muscles that are somewhere else so I
think the scaling of brain size with
body size is a little bit inevitable
just because you have to kind of have
the base place where each muscle is
going to be controlled and an
interesting question when the animal
gets bigger why doesn't it just get
bigger muscles rather than more muscles
I think it does get bigger muscles but I
think it also ends up with more muscles
and exactly how that scales I don't know
and I don't remember ever seeing
something about that
so
the question
um
of
once you have a brain of a certain size
is it the case that
the
the the sort of the bigger the brain the
smarter the critter
I think there's some evidence for that
but it's a little bit unclear like for
humans there was a big fashion a hundred
and well a bit more than 100 years ago
there was a whole field of science
called phrenology that had to do with
the shapes to people's heads and
conclusions about the personality of the
person based on the shape of their head
it's one of those areas of science that
fell into absolute disrepute
I don't know whether there's any uh
sensible meaningful things that could be
deduced from it what tends to happen in
science is people get very enthusiastic
about something and then sometimes the
enthusiasm is is too hyped up and the
thing just crashes completely and then
it's lost for 100 years or 200 years and
people say oh no no you don't you know
that's a bad idea type thing I I suspect
phrenology was used for some rather
silly purposes and you know things like
is this a good person or a bad person
let me see whether there's a bump on the
on the side of their head in this
particular place that's a very a very
unconvincing Direction
but the um
uh so you know there was a whole lot of
work that was done on kind of and a
whole lot of kind of these crazy maps
that showed Oh you know if you're ahead
judged if your skull juts out in this
place that means you're a good forward
thinker or something like that
um or or whatever
uh but I think the question of the sort
of correlation between kind of brain
size and mental capacity it's a rather
unconvincing one I mean for example
there are people who have the misfortune
of having uh high pressure fluid in
their brains which means that the sort
of central region inside the brain that
has fluid in it is big and the actual
brain is sort of squashed to the outside
of the skull
um I know that there are people who are
perfectly happily leading their lives
and doing all sorts of clever things and
they had no idea that the volume of
their brains was actually quite small
until somebody did an MRI and discovered
that and now that's interesting but
doesn't really make much difference to
them so there's you know that sort of a
counter example to the kind of idea that
the brain volume is what determines sort
of mental capacity it could be the case
that in some of those situations the
total number of nerve cells is is still
large and that what matters is the
number of nerve cells now you know one
of the things that was for a long time a
real mystery was how many nerve cells do
we actually have in our brains and you
might say well why don't you just look
and see well the problem is that if you
look under a microscope at a little
slice of brain you'll see all kinds of
of of neurons of nerve cells there but I
mentioned before that each nerve cell
can have like 10 000 sort of tentacles
sticking out of it and so being able to
figure out what the kind of connection
between this nerve cell and that nerve
cell and the other one is from
microscope size they're really difficult
there's a big uh sort of Citizen science
project trying to trace some of those
things but I think what happened
recently and I I was always mystified
why this wasn't a generic thing to do is
you know the brain has all these nerve
cells they're all kind of held together
by all sorts of sort of connective
material if you could just sort of
dissolve everything
wouldn't you just wind up with some
number of nerve cells and you can just
count them and uh you know that it's
it's rather easy to count cells there
are all sorts of devices where you let
cells drop uh down in in
um uh um cell cytometry
um
that's yeah the the um where where you
where you kind of drop individual cells
down and you have kind of uh laser
devices that are just counting the
individual cells as they as they uh uh
drop down
and why can't you why couldn't you just
do that sort of dissolve a brain and
just see how many nerve cells there are
there well finally people who have done
that and the claim is for humans that
they're around 86 billion nerve cells at
least I've seen in that number a bunch
of times I don't know whether that's one
particular brain or whether that's sort
of closely whether all brains are sort
of closely uh connected with with that
number of nerve cells but it's on the
order of 100 billion of cells
um and I don't know how much variation
there is uh and that would be something
one could ask about
but I think then the question is if you
have more nerve cells is it a good thing
well you know we have a little bit of
evidence from the chat gpts and the
large language models and the artificial
neural Nets that it does seem to be the
case that having more weights more
connections between artificial neurons
does seem to have an effect on the uh on
the performance of these large language
models and maybe there's even a
threshold below which it's kind of hard
to have enough linguistic information
enough Common Sense knowledge to be able
to sort of do human-like discourse so to
speak
and maybe that also is a limit you know
maybe it's the case that uh sort of the
Reason cats can't talk like humans in
part is they just aren't above that
threshold and the number of nerve cells
given the complexity of the language
that we humans have developed which
after all we got to develop because we
have that number of nerve cells so to
speak and maybe you know when the sort
of superhuman aliens arrive not that I
think that's quite how it will play out
uh that have you know brains that are 10
times the size of ours maybe they'll
have a language that has more words in
it
um I'm not sure
I don't tend to think that's how it's
going to work uh forget the forget the
absence of the aliens but even if for
example you know let's imagine and
there's no evidence this is the case
that human evolution is going in the
direction of sort of bigger brains that
there's no evidence to my knowledge that
that's the case there's no evidence that
over the course of recorded human
history that our species has changed the
size of the the skull that encloses the
brain which again is kind of if you
believe that being smart is in some
sense is kind of of value to an
individual in the species you might
think that in the course of biological
evolution that you would see sort of
bigger brain cases to enclose bigger
brains for the smarter humans who are
the more successful humans so to speak
there doesn't seem to be very much
evidence for that
so I think Although our species does
have a larger brain enclosure size than
previous hominid species
but I think um uh so
this question of sort of more neurons
bigger brains is it better do you do you
get to know more if you have a bigger
brain it's not even obvious that well I
I I have to say that my own personal
anecdotal feeling would be the more you
know the easier it is to solve problems
but I'm not sure that that is people's
Universal impression sometimes it's the
more you know the more distracted you
get
um but I I don't personally I don't
think that's the case
um but that's just an anecdotal claim
based on my personal experience rather
than some sort of scientific uh
conclusion about sort of what it takes
to solve problems versus what it takes
to to know things up front so to speak
now the other part of this question had
to do with uh computer trips and so on
and whether as they get smaller they get
smarter and and not not really I mean
the the the sort of the the the chips
that now have like billions of
transistors on them these are pretty big
things I mean they're several inches
across their size is usually limited by
things like the size of of uh piece of
silicon crystal which you can have
without having defects on the Crystal
and things like this although although
there are technological ways around that
where you make something that has
defects in it you test it you realize oh
that part doesn't work properly this is
commonly done for memory chips that part
doesn't work properly so let's just blow
out some sort of fuses on the the edge
of the chip that will mean that whenever
we're sending data into the thing it
avoids the plots that don't work
so it isn't necessarily limited by that
but the thing that does happen is that
one tries to pack
sort of denser and dense circuitry into
microprocessors and sort of the big
threshold now is five nanometers which
is uh that's the that's essentially the
size of the wires so that's um
um
five billionths of a meter
um is the uh
um
is is the size of the uh size of the
features size of the essentially the
wires now it's it's good to have smaller
wires because the smaller the chip is
the less time it takes for electrical
signals to go from one part of the trip
to the other and the the smaller the
wire the less there's kind of capacity
the sort of electrons that have to build
up to send that signal
um by the way makes me wonder in the
case of brains if you had a really big
brain maybe you would think really
slowly because you would have to wait
longer for the nerve impulses to go from
one side of the brain to the other I'm
not sure that's a significant effect
because I think that the the typical
time for
um well let's see we can probably work
it out
uh
it's a few milliseconds for one
between firings of different nerve cells
so I yeah that's interesting so I I'm
not sure if it's a significant effect to
say oh you have well if it had to go
through more
uh Junctions so to speak to get from one
side of the brain to the other if sort
of your brain instead of being a length
50 sort of relay chain of nerve cells
was a length 300 relay chain of nerve
cells so to speak maybe you would think
more slowly because you'd be waiting for
what is the other side of my brain think
about that
um and sort of coming to consensus in
what your brain wants to say next so to
speak might take longer
uh for in the case of a an artificial
neural net for example the difference
between chat gbt gpt3 gpd4 all these
kinds of things it's bigger networks and
the the thing that can happen I I don't
think we we know precisely how some of
these uh systems are built but in the
case of of uh gbt the original version
at least there were sort of 400 layers
that were involved so it took kind of
400 uh a sequence of 400 computations
and each of those 400 computations was
pulling in data from maybe a million
different artificial neurons but each
that that's kind of 400 sequential
computations that have to get done
um to get sort of the next token of
result
and so one could imagine in the case of
of a human brain that there's sort of
this question of of how long is that
relay
and the longer that might be the slower
the brain might think
so that's a um an interesting question I
don't know the answer to Is what the
reaction times of Critters like whales
and so on are my my kind of impression
would be they're quite slow but I don't
know for sure
um
although as I say the squid is fast
um I think uh uh so in in terms of
microprocessors computer chips and so on
the the individual features are getting
smaller and that
allows the chip to run faster as in so
to the way a trip works it's doing sort
of succession of instructions that come
from the program you specified and the
question is how fast it's going to do
those instructions and modern ships will
do maybe uh three billion instructions
per second so to speak
and that that's uh and so there's a
question of how fast can you uh have
successive instructions be done and the
smaller the features the lower the
transmission times the faster you can
have successive instructions be done
because you can't really have the next
instruction happen until there's been
time for an electrical signal to go
across the chip to deal with finishing
the previous instruction now in
actuality chips modern chips have all
sorts of coverness and all sorts of
things whether you're storing data very
close to where it's going to be used
so-called levels of caches L1 cache L2
level one level two level three cash
that are sort of
progressively higher speed you know the
level one cash is the highest speed sort
of closest in to where the data is going
to be used cash and what can take a lot
of time in a in a CPU is fetching data
from memory
um and so if you can prefetch things if
you know what data is going to be used
and you can get it ready then you don't
have to wait that time so a typical
thing would be if you have a whole array
of data you're working on well the the
let's say you're working on some image
or something like that and you kind of
know you're going to need the this next
piece of the image you can kind of load
that into this fast cache memory uh in
in advance so when you actually need to
compute with it so that the actual
computation can happen more quickly
without having to say oh now I need this
piece of the the what's for memory I
have to spend a lot of time going out to
main memory and going to fetch that
um and similarly there are all kinds of
tricks in microprocessors where things
like well what instruction are you going
to do next well let's guess what
instruction is going to do next and
let's be going to be done next and let's
just go ahead and do it and even if
there's a sort of Branch where it says
well if this happens then go do that
instruction if that happens then go to
that instruction
um the it's it's pretty common in modern
microprocessors to do so-called
speculative execution where you just
follow all the branches it's kind of
like the multi-way systems that we talk
about in our physics project where
you're kind of following all the paths
of what can happen well like a game
graph where you're looking at playing a
game and you're saying what are all the
possible moves you can make specular
execution unfortunately also ends up
being a source of all sorts of computer
security issues as you kind of watch
what happens on the speculative branch
and all kinds of different things happen
and you can kind of kind of reduce
things you want supposed to be deducing
based on what happens on on that
different
um
a different branch
let's see
uh
of a comments here let's see
um
huh Des is asking uh about neuron
connections allowing sort of
precognition
of um
uh
you know I think I think
sort of the best one could hope for is
figuring stuff out more quickly not
figuring out things from the future of
time so to speak
um
let's see
Harry is asking do you think the brain
can be trained or not like a muscle can
be trained
you know I think when you train your
muscles and you get stronger and all
that kind of thing I think you're
getting additional fibers in the actual
muscles
um and that that's uh a um that's a big
part of what's going on in the brain it
always used to be said that you were
born with a certain number of nerve
cells and all that would ever happen in
the course of your life is that nerve
cells will die you'd never get new ones
that turns out not to be the case there
are new nerve cells that are produced
the rate of new nerve cell production
and the amount that sort of thinking
every day does to make more nerve cells
get produced I don't think anybody knows
I think that the
the question I have to say I know
in my own very anecdotal case I do feel
that I think better for having thought
more so to speak the fact that I have
sort of do a lot of thinking helps me to
do a better job of thinking but I
suspect part of the reason for that part
of it may be physiological as in more
nerve cells are produced maybe possibly
I'm not sure uh part of it I think is
that one has certain patterns of
thinking and one gradually learns to
sort of say well if I'm going in this
direction I'm going to end up here well
let me remember that if I go in this
direction then I end up here I'll just
remember that directly so then the next
time around they don't have to go
through and work out this and this and
this it's like I go you know well I
could go one plus one plus one plus one
plus one and I know I can add up all
those ones and I can conclude that seven
or something or I can just remember the
rhythm of those ones and say oh that's
seven and I can kind of then go directly
it's kind of a a how do you beat sort of
the computational irreducibility of what
you have to work out well you just
remember the answer and I think
increasingly if one has certain types of
things one thinks about I mean in
general yeah I mean in general one of
the things to say about brains is that
you know training
one can get trained to do all sorts of
things you know if one's doing some
complicated kind of activity you know
whether it's well riding a bicycle
flying a plane doing some kind of
programming whatever else it is uh
gradually as one does more of it one can
get to the point where one can both do
it more quickly and do it more reliably
but particularly more quickly and my
guess is that happens because we're
basically just establishing memories
that are if this this this happened boom
you know the answer you don't have to go
think it through you just know the
answer it's kind of like a caching
strategy where you're you're just saying
uh I'm I'm just I just store the result
I don't have to compute anything so that
that's my suspicion here
um
uh JH asks how will brains change
through neural links connecting directly
to AI
you know I've talked about this a few
times I I think that
this
whole question
first of all there's the whole question
of what does the neural user interface
look like
in what what's the way that you get this
collection of electrodes sort of
connecting to a piece of your brain how
does that
how does how do those electrodes sort of
present their signals to the brain and
it's kind of like our eyes in some sense
are doing this there are a bunch of
photoreceptors in our eyes where
particles of light photons hit the
retina of our eyes they produce little
pulses of electricity which go down our
optic nerves and then the bad design of
alien brains they go all the way through
the brain to the visual cortex to the
back of the brain and then they start
producing electrical activity in the
brain but so in a sense we have a neural
link it's our eyes that go from light to
nerve nerve impulses electrical impulses
in our in our nerve cells in our brains
and so there's sort of in our eyes are
arranged in a certain way and they
present a certain neural interface to
our brains and as we start thinking
about uh kind of additional
kinds of interfaces to our brains we
have to say well you know for example
eyes present their their neurons in a
physical array that is the arrangement
of uh pixels on our retinas so you know
there's a there's a place on your brain
if if there are pixels that go from left
to right that is actually mapped into
particular nerve cells that kind of go
maybe it's even from right to left I
think it inverts
um that uh in one's brain and for
example for once two eyes
those nerve signals from Once two eyes
are mixed together and if you kind of
look at kind of which nerves are paying
attention to each eye it's kind of a
pattern that looks a bit like a zebra
stripe pattern possibly because it's
made from a reaction diffusion process
not unlike the process that makes zebra
stripes but playing out in in terms of
collections in the brain but that means
that you're kind of getting that that
sort of part of the of the neural
interface from our eyes to our brain is
that the two the two eyes are sort of
mixed together in that way so first step
is you know what's the technology of the
neural interface and what how do you
present the information that's coming in
on this neural interface
and then also how does the neural
interface get something from our brains
how do we learn to send it the
information it needs to be sent and I
suspect that that's will be ultimately
very similar to how do we learn to type
how do we learn to do any of these other
things which are kind of a way of taking
a thought and actuating it in something
which involves some orchestrated
arrangement of nerve impulses my guess
is that we'll kind of have to learn by
the same sort of feedback mechanisms and
so on that we learn to do lots of other
kinds of activities they'll probably be
a kind of a training of how to do sort
of connect to your neural interface type
thing what will it feel like I think it
will kind of
feel like
well any kind of sort of feedback that
you have like you know you move your
your arm and you feel this thing and
that's sort of a a thing happening from
the outside world it's kind of like you
uh or even
um you do something on your computer and
your computer responds that's like
you've done something you've actuated
something you've pressed this button and
something comes back my guess is it will
feel very much like that that it'll be
that you feel I'm doing something it
isn't something where you can see what
you're doing it's not like oh I can see
that finger moving it's it's something
that you're sort of imagining going on
and it will then come back from what you
think so to speak something will come
back from that just like kind of I
wonder what will happen if I press this
button and then you do it and something
comes back and it happens to go through
your eyes but I don't think it will be
that different going directly into into
brains and I think
there are many kind of more Junior
versions of this that one starts to
wonder about like for example as soon as
we have a sort of good augmented reality
capabilities there's the question of can
we see things around us that are Beyond
kind of the ordinary images that we see
with ordinary visible light very obvious
question can we see into the ultraviolet
can we see into the infrared can we see
more
Precision of the frequencies of light
that we're seeing not just as it red
green blue which is what we currently
have sensors for in our eyes but you
know is it producing light right at that
particular frequency that tells us that
it's a particular material for instance
and um the uh the thing that um
uh that we um uh that one wonders is
okay you're having this kind of enhanced
Vision how do we present that enhanced
Vision to our brains well we could have
a direct neural interface that goes
beyond kind of the interface that we get
from our eyes our eyes are delivering
signals to the visual cortex the back of
our brains okay well what piece of real
estate in the brain are you going to
connect let's say you had a direct
neural interface what piece of real
estate in the brain are you going to
connect that information to you know
that's going to be an issue of well
whoops I've already used that part of my
brain for this you can't connect to that
then then you'd use up all my knowledge
of this or whatever it is so that's sort
of a question I don't know how that's
going to play out but that's one one
thing would be to take the infrared
channel so to speak and play it into a
piece of real estate in the visual
cortex
another possibility is to kind of
Multiplex the images that you already
see and kind of modify them in some way
like for example let's say you're seeing
this image and then something is kind of
flashing in that image let's say there's
a thing that's really hot you could see
that that um you know instead of just
seeing the thing as a uh sort of piece
of metal or something could be flashing
a different color you could still tell
oh it's a piece of metal because you can
kind of see it through the flashes so to
speak but uh that that the flashing you
know that they're using the time part of
things could uh could give you a better
way to kind of be able to perceive uh
sort of what sort of additional
information sort of multiplexed onto the
visual scene that you already have
so I I don't know what you know do you
get to use more real estate in the brain
that is sort of unused and send signals
indirectly so do you get to use the
current sort of nerve channels and sort
of put more information on them by for
example changing what you see in the
visual field and so on
the uh
um
Harry is commenting I think some parts
of our brains have adapted to Modern
laggy typing so we don't really perceive
it anymore yeah I mean one thing that
does tend to be the case is that that
people get used to things often more
quickly than they ever expect
so you know it's a it's a famous thing
in user interface design uh system
design that you tell humans oh your
computer is adapting to you
and they're like okay great that's why
it's getting so much easier to use the
system but actually the computer didn't
change at all it was the humans that
learned more about how to use the system
they just had the perception that the
system was adapting because they were
adapting and uh that was in a sense by
telling them the system adapts it was
just sort of an inducement for them to
persist longer in using the system
I think the thing that's often surprised
me like like for example at times in the
past hasn't happened recently when
computer keyboards were laid out
slightly differently and I would switch
from using One keyboard to another I was
amazed at how quickly my sort of touch
typing got got rewired I mean literally
it took like seconds for one to oh
that's a different keyboard okay that
that's there and there and there and
it's like okay now I'm typing I'm not
looking at my fingers I don't think I am
at least and yet I was able to use sort
of the rewired keyboard and it happened
really fast and I was surprised at how
how much one adapts to that and I think
that's you know that's the thing we have
going for us is we learn and often some
of these kind of sort of skills oriented
things are things that we learn quite
quickly I mean there are different parts
of our brains that are associated with
these kinds of manual skills the writing
a bicycle type thing as opposed to the
you know how do I figure out the answer
this philosophy question type thing
so let's see
um
uh
ah wolf comments something I didn't know
the claimers that the brains of Wales
have fewer neurons than humans but the
neurons are big it's interesting I
didn't know that
um
let's see cryo is making the interesting
statement that societies and groups are
like larger scale brains developing
interest and claim I mean it's kind of
like the ants which has 50 000 neurons
per ant brain you might say the whole
ant colony uh is kind of achieving
actually how does that compare how many
ants are there in ant colony I would
guess let me think
100 000 Maybe so let's see if that's if
that's right then that's um
uh
I see at a hundred thousand if I'm right
that that's right that's roughly right
then that would mean that they're uh
um
10 billion neurons in the whole ant
colony if they're 50 000 neurons per amp
roughly so still the ant colony doesn't
have as many neurons as a single human
brain
um but uh you know on an interesting
question is if if you look at the eight
billion humans each of whom let's say
has 100 billion uh uh brain cells that's
you know that's a big factor
um you know one's looking at um uh and
then the question is how efficient is it
to have sort of the coordinated effect
of sort of a whole group of humans as
compared to the sort of thinking of an
individual brain I have to say that the
sort of there's this question of the
coherence of thinking of an individual
brain versus the coherence of action of
a whole group of people and the sort of
a question of how that works and often
one thinks well gosh uh things you know
when all the humans are kind of doing
things in lockstep that's not very
interesting we want them all to kind of
be be learning separately it's kind of
the the the dream of kind of the
inventiveness of the humans it's like
with all those humans trying to invent
things they'll they'll be more
successful in inventing things than if
it's just one human doing it of course
what we actually know in practice is
that human organization in order to sort
of keep everything organized there is
there's more structure when you get more
humans trying to do things and often it
is harder for that one human who has the
great idea to kind of implement the
great idea because there's this big
institutional structure so to speak now
I wonder whether things like that happen
in brains too I mean in other words I
wonder whether when you have an idea
does that idea initiate with a small
number of neurons and then they have to
be fighting their way through your brain
to say yes that's really a good idea is
that the right picture of what's going
on that's an interesting question
something where I think one could start
to investigate that with artificial
neural Nets sort of where does the idea
originate
um and uh is it the case that you can
kind of Trace where the um I mean
there's a little bit that's been done
and I've even done and we've even done a
little bit of looking at the uh at sort
of of llms and asking questions like can
you identify where where in the llm some
thoughts start to develop it's not so
easy to do that but there's a few places
where you can kind of see some sort of
definite brain circuit in action but one
might be able to do that we might be
able to say where did the thought
originate what did it take for that
thought to sort of take over and be the
thought that was ended up being the you
know great that thought one it was the
next word interesting question actually
uh something to look at but
um but then the the issue would be what
is the comparison between the way that
we kind of uh sort of initiate and
promote ideas in society versus the way
pieces of our brains initiate and
promote ideas maybe there's something
great we'll learn maybe that's the next
fad of corporate organization is you
know organize your company like the
neurons in your brain are organized but
I don't think we know what that is yet
so uh well we know some things about how
brains are organized and they do tend to
you know form clumps and then sort of
super comps and so on so maybe that's
kind of like the hierarchical
organization of typical companies and
such like but that's a it's um
that's an interesting question what uh
what is the comparison between kind of
idea generation in an idea development
in brains and in societies uh and and
and is it the case that
sort of that's another question you know
is bigger better you know history does
not support the idea that bigger is
better in terms of the creation of new
ideas and all sorts of kinds of progress
um it is not the case that you know the
now sometimes sometimes the bigger
country wins because it simply has more
resources and more ability for people to
have the opportunity to do things like
invent or get their inventions paid
attention to but it's certainly not a
constant of history that the bigger
country is the more successful country
um it's uh you know sometimes it's just
they're an awful lot of people and it's
really hard to deal with that number of
people and in order to deal with that
number of people you have to organize
things in this or that way
let's see
uh cryo is asking would you imagine
bigger brains will run into heating or
cooling issues you know I think brains
you know an awful lot of the heat made
by us humans is made by our brains the a
lot is made by the liver as well but you
know you have to kind of worry about
losing heat from your head when you're
in a very cold place
and brains I think they use about some
uh
um
they use uh about 50 watts of um
uh of um uh of power
um and that's
that's significant fraction of the heat
generation of for us humans now if you
have a bigger brain does it use more
power
um
uh
I actually don't know
um I assume the answer is yes I assume
that the um uh you know when we we eat
to produce glucose to be able to sort of
power our brains I'm kind of assuming
that uh Critters with bigger brains have
to uh have to eat more to power their
brains and so there's more heat that
gets generated I don't think the issue
that happens with computers a lot which
is how do you dissipate the heat is so
much of an issue for brains I I don't I
think the reason is that we have an
awfully good cooling system because we
have blood vessels that are exchanging
heat you know in the brain we have
capillaries going reaching right down to
you know two millionths of a meter away
from everything there's a capillary
otherwise the otherwise we don't get to
have that piece of tissue live because
it has to have oxygen delivered to it
and that um so it's it's delivering
oxygen at that rate uh you know to every
part of the the the the the Lane and
it's also being able to take heat
exchanging heat between
any heat that's produced by the brain
and then
that's being sort of taken away by um uh
by the bloodstream
um and uh I think in computers
one has to have these rather elaborate
you know heat sinks and so on on a CPU
one would have something where there's a
but one's trying to get air to flow past
the chip to be able to take away the
heat from the chip but one doesn't have
something as convenient as a bloodstream
of capillaries and so on I mean there
have been at times uh computers that
were cooled with liquids and um there
were have been water cooled computers
there have been computers that are
cooled by uh uh that are cool that low
temperatures
um I remember back in the 1980s
seeing computers there were several one
of the more exotic ones supercomputers
of the time you could actually see the
bubbling
liquid uh with some kind of inert liquid
that was sort of flowing through the
actual circuitry of the computer to take
heat away
um and there certainly are even today
they're water cooled things but they
don't get in with capillaries and so on
so I think that that current technology
has it a lot harder than than brains
have it because brains have all those
capillaries that form
um
let's see
uh
well let's see Des is commenting that is
nature
more efficient
um
at doing things in electronics so much
so that we should use biological cells
for computation that's certainly been a
persistent thought
um what is true is that biology
has succeeded in doing sort of
orchestration of things at a molecular
scale
it's you know we talk about a five
nanometer feature size for
microprocessors that's getting down
there in terms of things the size of of
big biological molecules but still
there's one of the features of
microprocessors is they still tend to be
largely two-dimensional largely just in
a plane not built up in 3D whereas all
of our biological material most of
things in biology are built up in in
three dimensions and I think that that
uh the whole orchestration of you know
this molecule goes there this electron
this ion goes there that happens in
biological tissue with biological
molecules it's still something where we
don't have an analog of that that we can
sort of print out as microprocessor
chips or anything like that so there are
there are pieces to that where there are
sort of molecular level orchestration of
things that we don't yet know how to do
technologically I kind of feel like
there's a Direction Where just as
microprocessors use electrons for
everything in biology uh it's not just
electrons we're using other atoms and
molecules and so on to sort of Transport
both information and material around and
I kind of think that there's probably a
way to build technology around that idea
and to make sort of the analog of
microprocessors but transporting you
know I don't know what iron atoms and
sodium atoms and things like this rather
than just electrons around and that will
end up with something that is sort of
more biologically related in that way I
don't think that the idea of using
biology as such as the foundation for
doing sort of computational kinds of
things is a great idea I think that when
we have to interface to biology like
we're making medical devices and we have
to say this is going to attach to some
particular kind of cell then there's
more reason to do things kind of
biologically but if we're just trying to
compute you know the next abstract thing
I really don't think that's going to be
biological material I don't think that's
going to be little mini brains of
organoids that have been grown out of
brain tissue I don't think that's going
to be things sort of that are
biologically constructed that let one do
that things that are molecular scale yes
but things that are biologically
constructed no I think no more so than
um
uh the um uh then um uh saying oh you
know let's use horses instead of cars
let's use the thing that didn't work out
flocks of geese or something rather than
airplanes
um you know these were sort of
biological solutions that weren't a good
fit to the technological needs in the
case where one's dealing with medicine
biomedicine there may be more push to
use sort of truly biological things to
fit into that use case but in the case
of pure computation I don't think that's
the right way to go right I see I'm
being told that I'm late for a bunch of
other things here uh I do want to
mention that on Monday I believe it is
math storytelling day every day has to
be some kind of special day and it's
math story retelling day and I'm going
to do a math live stream about math and
I was hoping to uh uh at four o'clock
Eastern time U.S eastern time
um and uh I was hoping to kind of
be able to explain some math in an
interesting way and if people have uh
math that they would like explained
um including things that uh
you were sort of might have been
supposed to learn in school or something
like that I'll do my best to try to
explain those things
um and see whether I can uh do the
outrageous thing of sort of compressing
sort of math ideas that are supposed to
take semesters to learn into a short
time we'll see what I'm setting myself
up for that but anyway I'm looking
forward to having a chance to try and
explain some math uh 4 P.M eastern time
on a live stream
and uh
for now
um
uh we should wrap up here thanks for
joining me thanks for lots of
interesting questions I see a bunch that
we'll save up for next time
bye for now